[Music]
you are seeing the light
the lighting rather what the salvation
army calls the world's largest version
of its iconic
red kettle in new york's times square
this morning this is giving tuesday and
many of the non-profits are being forced
to change how they raise their funds
during this pandemic
now traditionally as you know the
salvation army collects donations at 25
000 red kettles across the country but
the organization anticipates a huge
decrease in traffic this year for
obvious reasons
so jamie yuka shows us how it's adapting
it's the sound of the holiday season
volunteer bell ringers have collected
donations at the salvation army's
iconic red kettles for decades but this
130 year old holiday tradition
is now facing an unprecedented challenge
as the pandemic is prompting many
shoppers
to stay home we work with a lot of
organizations
commissioner ken hotter is the national
commander of the salvation army
in terms of fundraising we anticipate
about a 50 percent drop what does that
mean in terms of dollars
last year the christmas kettle campaign
raised 126 million dollars across the
country
so we're looking at a decline of about
60 million at the same time the
organization which helps feed and house
those in need
is seeing an increase in demand it
serves more than 23 million americans
each year
and expects to help an additional six
and a half
million people this holiday season it's
a perfect storm
to adapt the kettles are going high tech
giving donors a contactless
option to pay electronically and the red
kettle campaign
is going digital enlisting celebrities
like caramel brown from the netflix hit
queer eye i didn't really expect to have
this moment with you
and you are such an amazing man brown
was a social worker in los angeles for
more than a decade
often referring his clients to the
salvation army
he also understands the pressure of
struggling families during the holidays
i'm a single father and even though i
worked in social services
we don't make a lot of money but i
remember times where i had to choose
between
a bill and giving my child
a gift had to choose between you know
putting gas in the car and you know
buying some extra food for the house
what was that like for you as a dad to
have to make those choices
it was heartbreaking i felt isolated i
felt alone
now he's sharing stories about the
salvation army's work
with his nearly 3 million social media
followers
he believes the pandemic has made
americans more empathetic
we're seeing this sort of shift of
connection where people are like i'm not
going to judge you for what you need
i'm going to support you because you've
asked for help when you look at the math
of how much more need there is this year
versus what the deficit could be
do you think you can pull this off i 100
believe we're gonna pull it off and the
reason is because i believe in
people i believe that we all at the the
core of us want to connect and want to
help and want to love each other
it's a new call to action with a